pues después de haber sido arrestada en
el hospital en el aeropuerto
internacional de washington aeropuerto
de emma coronel enfrentará su primera
audiencia en la corte del distrito de
columbia este lo mencionado a será de
forma virtual eba coronel que lleva
casada con el chapo guzmán desde el 2007
enfrenta cargos por conspirar para traer
heroína eeuu uno o más kilos de heroína
eeuu cinco o más kilos de cocaína
también y también metanfetaminas y
marihuana entre el 2014 y el 2017 los
fiscales del caso dicen que emma coronel
también ayudó a el chapo guzmán a
escapar de prisión en el 2015 y que ha
mantenido en la línea de mando para
distribuir las órdenes en el cartel
órdenes que supuestamente pues vienen
desde el chapo guzmán el defensor el
abogado de macrón él será llevé
lichtman quien fue también el abogado
defensor de el chapo guzmán y pues se
espera entonces que sea hoy entonces
esta audiencia de emma coronel también
ciudadana estadounidense